[Música]
necesito que me acompañen a jugar a un
juego se llama carrera en tecnología
para ganarlo tenemos que juntar 1000
puntos si lo logramos podemos llegar a
ganar millones
vamos a arrancar para eso como en
cualquier juego tenemos un personaje
el personaje que nos toca es una chica
de 17 años es muy curiosa es el mejor
promedio de la clase perfil que en su
infancia le regalaron una cocinita y
alarma en una computadora y en la
escuela ella nunca aprendió que las
mujeres se podían dedicar a la
tecnología
hoy saben que por eso arrancamos con
menos 100 de habilidades tecnológicas y
menos 100 de aspiraciones pero importa
estamos un poco abajo con ganas de
seguir llega nuestra próxima misión
lograr que un grupo de personas nos
felicité porque decidimos estudiar
ingeniería en sistemas
este juego nos está llevando primero al
grupo de amigos a ver qué nos dice el
grupo de amigos es una carrera donde
chabón es seguro va a ser difícil
vamos con la familia que nunca falla
tu mamá te dice por qué no te vas a lo
seguro abogacía o docencia
aunque acabamos de perder 70 puntos
buena noticia igual arrancamos en la
universidad ahora nuestra misión es
terminar la facultad vamos a ver cómo es
este nivel
cursamos en el quinto piso pero el único
baño de mujeres está en el primero
por llegar tarde a las clases perdemos
otros 50 puntos
como sigue esto tenemos el mismo
profesor en tres materias
siempre que una chica le hace una
pregunta no le responde
por no poder responder nuestras dudas
perdemos otros 30 puntos
bueno igual quiero contarles que
seguimos avanzando
logramos recibirnos este año somos una
de las pocas mujeres que se reciben de
esa carrera y conseguimos trabajo aunque
un par de personas nos dicen que es
porque hay mucha demanda en el mercado
de este rubro por este tipo de roles no
por tu promedio
ahora nuestra próxima misión es lograr
un aumento de sueldo
en que somos la única mujer en un grupo
trabajamos el doble nos esforzamos un
montón encima nos dan los proyectos más
difíciles sin embargo nos centramos un
día en el café
que nuestros compañeros ganan más
entonces vamos a hablar con nuestro jefe
y nos dice la culpa es tuya porque vos
nunca pediste un aumento de sueldo
este juego es agotador y me imagino que
ustedes como yo no quieren seguir
jugando
esto ya no es un juego estas frases son
algunos de los testimonios de las pocas
mujeres que en argentina trabajan en
tecnología
el año pasado hicimos una investigación
porque queríamos entender por qué a más
tecnología menos mujeres queriendo a
estudiarla o crearla
ellas nos contaron que estos eran
algunos de los recorridos y trayectorias
que tuvieron que pasar durante toda su
vida para lograr estar donde hoy están
no hay duda que todo lo que hacemos hoy
con tecnología marca el ritmo de
nuestras vidas
desde lo que compramos hasta
reencontrarnos con ese grupo de amigos
del secundario
el 89 por ciento de lo que hacemos en
internet tiene que ver con una
aplicación móvil pero sólo el 6% fueron
creadas por mujeres
meetic top instagram y facebook
es por eso hace muy poco tiempo apareció
un hemos y de una mujer con una
computadora
en argentina en la carrera de ciencias
de la computación hoy solamente hay un
11% de mujeres
esto no siempre fue así 50 años atrás si
íbamos al aula de esta carrera nos
íbamos a encontrar con que el 75% de las
personas que estudiaban eran mujeres las
mujeres no sólo eran mayoría se
destacaba de hecho gracias a ellas todo
lo que hacemos en las pantallas es
posible desde que la primera persona en
la historia de la humanidad que programó
fue una mujer ada lovelace hasta quien
inventó lo que hoy usamos como wifi
heidi la mar o miren esto quien creó el
software que logró llevar el hombre a la
luna
margaret hamilton medio irónico
este es un tema que a mí me ocupa y me
preocupa porque no es un territorio
donde las mujeres tenemos que conquistar
un territorio donde estábamos y dejamos
de estarlo
cuanto más fue creciendo la tecnología
como un lugar de distribución de riqueza
de poder es creatividad dejamos de
acceder
trabajar en tecnología hoy no solamente
es ganar el 30 por ciento más que en
cualquier otro rubro trabajar en
tecnología hoy es crear la arquitectura
de eso que hacen todos los otros
sistemas
dediquemos a lo que nos dediquemos va a
estar ahí
que no haya diversidad en esa mesa donde
se decide lo que vamos a hacer con esas
pantallas trae consecuencias para todas
las personas
por ejemplo si tomamos el asistente
virtual que con voz femenina nos
pregunta en qué puedo ayudarte y le
decimos en un momento de desesperación
asistente me quiero suicidar
el asistente te dice el número que
corresponde a tu país de software
localiza donde vos estás y te da ese
número exacto
ahora hasta hace muy poco tiempo si le
decíamos asistente me violaron los
instante te decía no entiendo lo que me
preguntas
después de muchas quejas ahora el
asistente te recomienda una url un sitio
web de violencia doméstica pero saben de
donde eeuu
que hoy la tecnología sea definida por
un solo grupo trae consecuencias para
todas las personas
y eso es algo que tenemos que tener en
cuenta
porque de nuevo tenemos que empezar a
pensar
las mujeres necesitamos estar de nuevo
en esa mesa de decisiones
en el 2015 un grupo de mujeres que
veníamos de diferentes ámbitos pero
todos atravesados por la tecnología
decidimos crear una organización y estar
ahí donde hoy hay que estar
motivando formando y acompañando a la
próxima generación de mujeres líderes en
tecnología
a ellas no solo les enseñamos
habilidades tecnológicas también les
enseñamos diferentes habilidades que
tienen que ver con el emprendedorismo
con poder crear otras estrategias para
liderar porque saben que no queremos que
cuando lleguen sean como steve jobs pero
con pelucas
cuando empezamos a esta organización nos
fuimos dando cuenta que esto era lo más
fácil
aunque no lo crean lo más complejo era
trabajar con las escuelas con las
universidades con las empresas para que
empiecen a entender ya verlas a ellas
como líderes pero también a preparar el
lugar para recibirlas
en este recorrido
entendimos que lo primero que teníamos
que hacer para medir impacto era tener
datos y empezamos a buscarlos empezamos
a buscar cuántas mujeres hay en
tecnología hoy en argentina por ejemplo
y este dato no existía así que aunque no
nos dedicábamos a eso tuvimos que
investigar
hoy por ejemplo sabemos que en los
últimos cinco años de cada 100 personas
que se inscriben en estas carreras sólo
16 son mujeres
y ustedes pensaron bueno eso es un dato
que le sirve solamente a la organización
y ahora es que no cuando lo publicamos
empezaron a escribirnos un montón de
ministerios incluso grupos de inversores
para agradecernos y decirnos que estaban
usando esos datos que gracias a eso
ahora podían proyectar porque ahí donde
no se puede garantizar diversidad no va
a haber innovación y la tecnología se
alimenta de innovación
lo que aprendimos este tiempo es que no
es suficiente con enseñarles a las
chicas a sortear estas barreras tenemos
que entender de qué están hechas por qué
están ahí y por qué todavía persisten
eso no les va a ayudar solamente a ellas
también va a ayudar a otros grupos que
son minorías o que no están en esas
mesas de decisión es fundamental que las
mujeres recuperemos el lugar que supimos
tener en la tecnología
no es una tarea solamente nuestra es una
responsabilidad colectiva porque si lo
logramos ya va a dejar de ser sólo un
grupo el que diseña el futuro mientras
que el resto nos quedamos atrapados o
fuera del juego
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bien